una nueva caravana de emigrantes
hondureños recorren decenas de
kilómetros en medio de la noche miles de
hombres y mujeres siguen el camino de un
sueño difícil de alcanzar pero que les
da esperanzas de un futuro mejor porque
aquí en la cosa que no podemos trabajar
refugiado y mayor de edad y todos pero
aquí el estudio todo lo que es el
trabajo no podemos realmente queremos
buscar una vida mejor en nuestra buscar
un futuro mejor o sea pues realmente lo
que necesitamos una vida mejor para
nuestros vídeos también para la familia
también en lo que va del año han salido
al menos cuatro caravanas de inmigrantes
hondureños la pantalla de kobe 19
agudizó la crisis en el país
centroamericano
este grupo partido del miércoles en la
noche de san pedro sula en el norte de
honduras hacia el punto de corinto
fronterizo entre honduras y guatemala
[Aplausos]
luego de caminar toda la noche una ola
de personas se congregó en la frontera
en nuestro país no hay los médicos
suficientes para lo que uno necesita
entonces tenemos que mirar me entiendes
para otros países las autoridades
guatemaltecas no lograron evitar el paso
de miles de hondureños en un mensaje
radial el director del instituto
guatemalteco de migración pidió
colaboración al país vecino pedimos a
las autoridades hondureñas que detengan
estos flujos en su territorio esto no se
puede repetir pero si miles de
hondureños sueño con llegar a eeuu el
presidente de trump que busca la
reelección en los comicios de noviembre
ha adoptado una línea dura hacia la
inmigración legal e ilegal en lo que
lleva en la casa blanca su
administración ha anunciado planes para
permitir que sólo 15 mil refugiados se
reubiquen en eeuu en el año fiscal 2000
21 que comenzó este jueves